[Musique]
et
thomas chritophe bonjour on va parler de
votre film les promesses qui sorti il ya
quelques semaines avec isabelle huppert
et reda kateb notamment et et c'est ce
qu'ils racontent tout justement le la
bataille d'une femme qui est qui maire
d'une ville de banlieue
pour sauver sa vie pour sauver aussi un
quartier qui est rongé par la
désespérance des habitants lévénez des
choses qui ne marchent pas l'eau qui
fuit et enfin toutes et tous des choses
de la vie quotidienne plus des marchands
de sommeil
alors on va on va parler un peu de ce
film est peut-être est-ce qu'on pourrait
dire au fond
ça fume sur le courage politique ou
d'une certaine politique certain
engagement politique au nom bien sûr
enfin je crois que c'est un film sur le
voile sur l'engagement où on s'approche
un peu de ce que peut être le coup le
courage politique et et c'est un peu de
ce mot là que je suis parti du courage
souvent pour ces on part d'une idée un
petit peu théorique et
et moi j'avais cette idée un peu
théorique jamais jamais jamais envie de
m'approcher de sa du courage ou de la
lâcheté politique et je me disais
vraiment que c'était dans le domaine
local que je que je pourrais
potentiellement approché des personnages
de ça parce que la place du maire dans
la politique française qui est un peu
comme on dit parfois entre guillemets la
courroie de transmission le mécano de la
république un peu au coeur de
l'échiquier politique entre d'un côté
une proximité l'exposition permanente
sans filtre avec les habitants avec les
citoyens les gens regret voilà ils se
font violer ou par foyer la confiance
parfois la méfiance parfois de l'amour
de l'amitié et aussi ils ont ils sont
exposés à l'état central aux plus hautes
sphères à la technocratie puis au lieu
de pouvoir pas parisien
qui cadre un petit peu leur activité et
dont parfois ils ont besoin pour
résoudre des gros problème de cette
ville notamment le problème d'urbanisme
d'insalubrité du quartier que le
personnage principal et s'agacer des
verts verdun qui s'appelle le fierté des
bernardins dans le film justement donc
l'un des grands
boulot de cette femme pourquoi une femme
que vous avez choisi
j'ai pas vraiment réfléchi à ça près a
posteriori je peux peut-être le
justifier mais bat pour notre première
idée avec jean-baptiste delafon à qui
j'ai écrit le scénario c'était de
d'avoir un duo baptiste delafon qu'est
votre co scénariste du baron noir le
baron noir je connais très bien la vie
du compte la billettique exactement et
voilà qu'ils avaient travaillé aussi
cette sphère la la sphère plus nationale
et donc on s'est trouvé avec cette envie
aussi de parler de politique locale et
notamment de la figure du maire de
banlieue et de son équipe et de leur
directeur de cabinet tel qu'il est mais
quatre étoiles et son directeur de
cabinet mais voilà on trouvait que
c'était des figures un peu voilà sous
exposé sous exploité dans la fiction
donc pourquoi une femme je ne sais pas
je pense que en fait c'est très naturel
c'est assez naturel ce duo on cherchait
un duo contrasté de persona 2 à deux
moments différents de leur vie politique
elle va bientôt s'arrêter lui va bientôt
quitter cette ville dans laquelle il est
né dans lequel il a fait son ascension
politique et sociale et il veut vivre à
paris voulait continuer sa carrière à
paris donc il y avait ces contrastes la
d origine un peu différente et puis
évidemment une femme et en tant cette
relation un petit peu d'amitié
professionnels un peu maître élève aussi
qu'on peut avoir dans dans ce type de
rapports dircab et mer voilà qui est on
est très proche est-ce que la matinée le
professionnel son soulier son voilà
c'est les frontières se tient
complètement clair et en même temps en
même temps ça reste profession ça reste
assez professionnel probablement que
l'idée d'avoir une femme c'est aussi 2
2 - être dépendant d'eux je pense qu'on
a beaucoup plus de deux clubs de clichés
de sur ce que peut être un homme
politique qu'on le territoire pour nous
était aussi un petit peu plus vierge
avait avec une femme et que je dirais
que c'est c'est quelqu'un quand le film
commence qui est quelqu'un d'intègre qui
essaient de faire de la politique un
petit peu différemment de ce que l'on
peut imaginer et probablement quand on
la voit un peu frôlé un peu une zone
d'ombré un peu une zone d'ombré intimés
est un peu politique et d'ambition j'ai
l'impression aussi que c'est un petit
peu plus surprenant si c'est une femme
que si c'est un homme se serait attendu
par les deux sets d'autres formations
c'est à un moment
on l'appelle pour lui proposer de
devenir ministre évidemment c'est très
intéressant parce que on voit comment à
cette femme qui sait
qu'ils aient travaillé jour et nuit pour
pour sa ville tout d'un coup quand même
il ya cette petite ambition qui rend
chaque comme nous et qui m'aime ouais
tout à fait
ça ouvre
probablement elle s'est fait un plan de
fin de carrière elle n'a pas
complètement prévisible
elle veut arrêter elle a prévenu la
santé elle a prévu d'arrêter elle
s'était toujours dit qu'elle ferait de
mandat elle va faire deux mandats le
seul truc elle a trouvé même sa
successeure qui est jouée par n'aidera
ya dis donc elle à quelqu'un qui va
prendre sa suite son adjointe et elle
veut juste régler un dernier mme
dernière chaussée obtenir une subvention
un plan de sauvetage pour pour cette
cette cité des berlouffes certains pays
d'aller chercher de l'argent voilà
l'état quoi complètement c'est ça c'est
ça c'est sa dernière bataille et puis
voilà ce set cette proposition un peu
inattendu et inespéré
dont elle avait peut-être jamais rêvé
voilà va bousculer un petit peu bas un
petit peu tout ce qu'elle avait prévu
est aussi la bousculer un peu tout
simplement existentiellement quoi et
donc on va cents
pour servir qui se bat pour cette cité
des bernardins avec
comment vous avez rencontré je crois pas
mal de de vraies mères enfin sur
grigny je crois la maire de chanteloup
living with avec catherine arnould on a
rencontré ouais je dirais six sept huit
maires après on a voilà il y avait
notamment le maire de grigny philippe
riou et le maire de clichy-sous-bois là
où on a tourné olivier klein voilà qui
sont deux mers vraiment aux prises avec
avec des grandes copropriétés dégradées
insalubre et qui ont fait le type de
combat que et qui on a rencontré aussi
voilà beaucoup de maires de banlieues
donc catherine arnoux à
chanteloup-les-vignes nesrine manawar à
bezons etc etc un pivot qui à chaque
fois aussi beaucoup leur équipe
a pris
et nous avons appris beaucoup de choses
après il ya un certain nombre de choses
quand on se documente pour un film qui
sont des choses très très précis c'est
de comprendre des mécanismes voilà le
mais des mécanismes d'urbanisme de
mécanismes d'aller obtenir une
subvention
le mécanisme de la lutte contre les
marchands de sommeil et puis on essaie
de comprendre aussi comment ça travaille
comme en ville mairie comment les gens
travaillent ensemble et puis après
évidemment il ya aussi quelque chose
avec leurs figures avec la manière dont
ils vivent leur engagement mais mythique
hôtel
on peut s'interroger qu'est ce qui
pousse des gens se battre comme ça pour
d'autres ce qui est le vrai sens de la
politique au fond mais complètement
alors pour le coup c'est pas moi c'est
pas une question que je me pose beaucoup
en discutant avec tous ces maires avec
tous ces jours je ne cherchais pas à
retourner à la source de leur engagement
politique après il se trouvait que
beaucoup beaucoup avait un engagement
politique de longue date ou avait déjà
fait avant d'entrer en politique des
métiers qui étaient des métiers de
vocations des métiers tournés vers les
autres elle et elle est médecin dans le
catalina redoux comme catherine arnould
voilà il ya beaucoup de gens qui
viennent de ce type de lieu là où si on
crée un tissu relationnel et de
connaissance et qui eux aussi sont des
métiers tournés vers les autres et
beaucoup de gens aussi qui viennent de
l'éducation nationale voilà qui rentrent
en politique après où en politique
locale moi ce qui m'intéressait pas ce
n'était pas forcément d'aller aux
sources de doux et l engagement ou deux
de l'expliquer mais expliquer tout ce
bordel qui se passe dans la tête d'un
élu entre son engagement ses convictions
ses fragilités son intimité cette
ambition personnelle on a souvent
tendance dans les films a opposé
ambitions personnelles intérêt général
mais dans la tête d'un élu dans la tête
de quelqu'un qui travaille en politique
les choses sont beaucoup plus compliqué
que ça ce tiraillement il est il et il
est intérieure il n'est pas aussi blanc
et noirs si on n'a pas d'ambition
personnelle comment peut-on être
ambitieux pour sa ville c'est aussi
toute la question des promesses est ce
qu'on va les tenir et ce qu'on va pas
les tenir mais aujourd'hui on a un sens
un petit peu désabusé en français par
rapport à l'éthique sur sur les
promesses et pour moi il n'y a pas de
cas pas d'ironie dans ce titre là même
si évidemment il ya des promesses qu'on
tient pas dans six mois mais il est
intéressant de diable les promesses
parce que pourrait il ya quand même une
grosse différence qu'on voit dans le
film entre ce pouvoir local et on se
fait engueuler on est là il faut vous
rendre des comptes les choses qu'on peut
on les voit tout de suite
qui est plus en plus dans le cynisme on
a presque l'impression qu'ils intérêts
qui sait le monde et division d'autant
ce pouvoir aucun qui croient aux
promesses et l'autre qui n'y croient pas
c'est un peu simpliste comme un autre
j'espère qu'on a on a rendu ça je crois
que c'est aussi une question de distance
et d'objectifs le film on voit comment
cette situation le sujet du film cet
homme cet enjeu de cette cité qui va
traverser finalement beaucoup de strates
du du pouvoir et le film va de 7 de
cette cage d'escalier inondées au début
du film des bernardins jusqu'aux plus au
palais du pouvoir français et on voit
comment ça ça résonne et comment aussi
le consensus c'est un peu toujours
impossible et comment en fait à chaque
strate de l'état on a d'autres objectifs
une autre hiérarchie d'autres manières
de voir les choses de la distance et on
a un commissaire au grand paris qui fait
ce qu'il appelle des arbitrages et qui
lâche rien
famille très valable est finalement
beaucoup de vent beaucoup de villes qui
partagent les mêmes difficultés se
retrouvent en concurrence pour obtenir
des crédits des crédits de l'état et va
falloir choisir le meilleur dossier et
je pense que ça aussi ça raconte un
petit peu ce que ce que vivent les
maires servir d'un côté ils connaissent
les gens les habitants ils ont le poids
parfois des promesses qu'on met du temps
à tenir 2 voilà on connaît les problèmes
de chacun des habitants lors leur nom
les connais personnellement depuis des
années on connaît parfois les noms de
leurs enfants et tous et tous ces gens
là on va essayer de défendre leur cause
parfois au dessus et on va les défendre
dans des temps très restreint avec un
dossier avec des tableaux excel avec un
plan d'urbanisme des plannings et c'est
enfin voila c'est c'est au bout d'un
certain temps ça le film traverse voilà
il ya peu km entre la banlieue et paris
et autres et en même temps voilà on voit
que tout ce parcours du film est beau
bordel tu me dis c'est quoi vous avez
nombre de la sortie du film et
des projections pesant dans ces villes
là et quel était le jeu retour justement
des maires qu'ils ont vu s qui sont
retrouvés dans le rôle de père ouais oui
oui ils sont retransformés non non ils
se sont retrouvés c'était assez moi
j'étais assez étonné en fait sert que
j'ai montré le film
j'ai montré le film d'abord à des
directeurs de cabinet et donc là il y
avait une joie chez eux avoir ce
métier-là représentait au cinéma parce
que c'est un métier ça c'est un métier
assez méconnu donc le métier que le cube
reda kateb dans le film ait eu parfois
c'est un métier ils ont même dans leur
famille les gens ça comprennent pas
vraiment ce qui est exactement ce sens
un métier à géométrie variable qui est
un métier très très très exigeant et qui
peut mener à plein d'autres à d'autres
mandats chez les mères je pensais pas
que j'aurais dire est ce
cette satisfaction à être représentés ou
être correctement représenté parce que
c'est des gens qui ont une exposition
médiatique plusieurs etc mais
probablement que certains en tout cas
dans ce qu'ils m'ont dit trouver que
souvent la fiction ne faisait pas
justice serait alors de la réalité de la
vêtir à la réalité dans l'annexé est
aussi à la réalité de leur combat et de
leurs difficultés effectivement
notamment le fait de choisir comme sujet
principal le logement qui est un sujet
totalement viscéral c'est un sujet
essentiel de la politique locale mais
c'est aussi un sujet compliqué et ça
c'est
maintenant à des missions parfois ça
peut être gênant mais c'est aussi ouvrir
le film il faut regarder
les normes suspense dans le dernier dans
la dernière partie du film qui voit là
on est scotché c'est ce qu'on a essayé
de traduire et ça vient aussi un peu de
la de la vie ou de ce qu'ont appris au
contact des mères c'est à dire le la
multiplicité des sujets qui
s'entrecroisent
leleu la gestion crise en permanence et
voilà l'urgence l'attention l'objectif
du film un moment enfin pour nous en
termes d'expériences cinématographiques
quand vous parlez suspense sur la
dernière demeure c'est d'arriver à ça
c'est de raconter voilà donc d'une
manière réduite dans un film d'une heure
et demie 1h40 voilà ce que c'est que
cette énergie ce que c'est que cette
ville est en fête à ce que je voulais
dire par là c'est qu'il grand réalisme
dans les halls 1 mais en même temps
c'est un vrai film dépeint ce
documentaire mais c'est aussi parce que
chez les moeurs il ya du compte à
rebours alors il ya de la tension tout
est rapport de force en politique tout
est lui tout est affrontements à lunas
consensus ne se trouve jamais et donc en
fait dans la dans le réel il ya les
germes d'un thriller et donc nous on a
essayé de retraduire ça dans un film
sans faire appel à des poursuites en
bagnole on a un peu peur mais est ce que
c'est est ce que c'est que cette cette
vivacité cette brutalité et surtout et
ça aussi qu'on a qu'on a vu chez chacun
des élus de leur équipe cette énergie
cette énergie extraordinaire qu'on
dépasse elle court pour prévenir
asymptomatiques c'est un combat c'est un
combat et c'est vrai qu'on parle de de
courage on a parlé de courage au début
de l'interview c'est vrai que moi je
suis partie de ça un peu qu'est ce que
le courage politique et pour beaucoup
est dans un groupe nous avons beaucoup à
la politique d'une façon générale
secourir et là on voit pas d eau sol
terrain qui troublent consacrent leur
vie quoi qui consacrent leur vie c'est
aussi ce qu'on donne à ça c'est aussi un
peu la persévérance le courage c'est pas
que des très beaux sentiments tout il ya
rien de rien de complètement pure et en
même temps voilà il ya de la volonté il
ya une dépense d'énergie finalement pour
les autres et même si on sent que les
moteurs de l'engagement individuel d'un
homme ou d'une femme politique sont sont
compliquées et ont tiré sur perche alors
6 mai puis ça c'est ça qu'on essaye de
faire dans cinna c'est à dire de faire
un film qui soit pas
qu'ils montrent ce qui est beau dans
l'engagement et en même temps qu'ils
soient pas
qu'ils ne soient pas en génie qui ne
soit pas non plus cyniques même si
parfois les personnages le sont voilà
parce que le cynisme est aussi existe ça
fait partie de la politique et on peut
être cynique et engager enfin voila
c'est un petit peu comme je disais tout
à l'heure si vous leur permettez selon
le bordel tient dans la tête dans la
psyché d'un un homme ou une femme
politique c'est très réussi
bravo merci beaucoup donc ça s'appelle
les provinces affichent ils avaient les
pères la comptable mais il ya de foot de
deux personnages
exceptionnels oui je crois
bravo et merci merci beaucoup merci à
vous
[Musique]